another
major story that is that is undermining
institutional trust these days is the
case of igor d'anchenko
so now according to the washington post
an analyst was a primary source for a
2016 dossier of allegations against
donald trump has been arrested on
charges that he repeatedly lied to the
fbi about where and how he got his
information officials said on thursday
igor denchenko's role in providing
information to british ex-spy
christopher steele who compiled the
accusations about trump in a series of
reports has long been a subject of
scrutiny from internal department of
justice investigators and special
counsel john durham according to people
familiar with the investigations steele
presented that dossier to the fbi it was
part of the basis for secret
surveillance court orders targeting
former trump adviser carter page as the
fbi investigated possible ties between
the 2016 trump presidential campaign in
russia so you remember the steele
dossier was used as the basis to target
carter page you remember that in january
of 2017 before trump's inauguration or
right after trump's inauguration james
comey approached donald trump and told
him about the steele dossier and that
mere telling him about the steele
dossier was used as the predicate for
buzzfeed then breaking the dossier wide
on its website without vetting any of
the details and this became the basis of
the trump-russia investigation
right trump had deep ties to russia and
for four long years all we heard was
that trump was a russian plant the
steele dossier was still being trotted
out as possibly true as late as like a
few weeks ago abc news's george
stephanopoulos stat sat down with
christopher steele and steele was
maintaining that much of the data in
there was still probably true well it
turns out that since 2017 like since the
beginning
of this saga since the early days of
2017 the fbi knew that the key source
for the seal dossier was lying to them
and didn't know that in 2018 not 2019 in
no prosecution no attempts to to quash
no public statement about why the steele
dossier was a load of crap none of that
they just kept investigating right the
mueller investigation just kept going
a 2019 report by the justice department
inspector general found major problems
with the accuracy of dan chenko's
information but the 39-page indictment
unveiled on thursday paints a more
detailed picture of claims that were
allegedly built on exaggerations rumors
and outright lies the indictment is
likely to buffer its republican charges
that democrats and fbi agents
intentionally or accidentally turned
cheap partisan smears into a high-stakes
national security investigation of a
sitting president doesn't just buttress
it it proves it
if the democrats wandered a bunch of
dirty probably russian provided
misinformation through the fbi and then
into the media and then back into law
enforcement hands where it was used as
the basis for large swaths of the
mueller investigation
the indictment suggests dan chankle may
have lied to christopher steele and
others about where he was getting his
information some of the material came
from a democratic party operative with
long-standing ties to democratic
presidential nominee hillary clinton
according to the charges rather than
even a well-connected russian with
insight into the kremlin so it turns out
that some of the information wasn't even
coming from russia it was coming from
inside the house from somebody who's
just working with hillary clinton
the washington post admits the
allegations cast new uncertainty on some
past reporting on the dossier by news
organizations including the washington
post
well it's too late everybody won their
pulitzers and donald trump is no longer
president so victory achieved gang
zanchanko appeared briefly thursday in
federal court in alexandria virginia
where his lawyer tried to enter a plea
of not guilty on his behalf for five
counts of making false statements the
judge didn't accept the plea because the
hearing was not in arraignment and
zenchenko was released
so andy mccarthy has a has a good piece
over at new york post about all of this
titled arrest illustrates how the steele
dossier was a political dirty trick
orchestrated by hillary clinton he says
denchenko has been charged with five
counts of line to the fbi in interviews
during 2017. as the bureau struggled in
futility to verify outlandish
allegations that donald trump and his
campaign were clandestine agents of the
kremlin
those allegations were compiled in the
so-called steele dossier which the fbi
relied on in obtaining surveillance
warrants from a secret federal court the
dossier was generated by the clinton
campaign its principal author was former
british spy christopher steele steele's
main source was danchenko a russian
native based in the united states who
worked at the brookings institute a
washington think tank whose former
president strobe talbot is a college
friend of bill clinton's who worked in
the clinton state department at
brookings zanchenko worked with fiona
hill later a member of trump's national
security council and a key witness in
the first trump impeachment over the
unrelated ukraine controversy it was
through hill that zanchenko became
acquainted with steele who ran a
london-based intelligence firm durham's
indictment alleges that denchenko lied
about two major points
first he fabricated the claim that the
president of the russian-american
chamber of commerce informed him that
during the 2016 presidential campaign
trump was involved in a well-developed
conspiracy of cooperation with putin
in reality that conversation never
happened
the chamber president is not identified
by name in the indictment after the
steele dossier became public however
there was intense speculation that the
chamber's founder sergey milian was a
steel dossier source
as i recounted my book on russiagate
says andy mccarthy million denied being
a source trashed the dossier is fake
news created by sick minds zanchenko is
also alleged to have concealed that one
of his sources for the information he
was giving to steal was a longtime time
party operative who is close to the
clintons having worked on both of bill
clinton's successful presidential
campaigns and hillary clinton's 2008
presidential campaign that source was
revealed on thursday to be chuck dolan a
public relations executive who had
russian contacts referred to as pr
executive one in the indictment the fbi
interviewed denchenko because it was
desperately trying to corroborate the
steele dossier claims one question
jerome must be pressing is what took the
bureau so long the obama doj brought the
fbi's sworn claims to the secret federal
foreign intelligence surveillance court
in october 2016.
the fbi is supposed to verify the
allegations before going to court but it
didn't interview zanchenko who was the
main source until january 2017.
it was already obtaining its second
90-day spy warrants on carter page by
that point
it appears that durham theorizes the
trump-russia collusion narrative was a
political attack manufactured by the
clinton campaign relying on zanchenko
steele compiled the reports for glenn
simpson co-founder of an intelligence
firm fusion gps which specializes in
digging up political dirt fusion gps was
retained by perkins coy the clinton
campaign's law firm
in september durham indicted former
perkins quite michael sussman for making
a false statement to the fbi while
peddling trump-russia allegations the
bureau eventually found to be
unsubstantiated
durham
his charging instruments suggest the
clinton campaign used its agents to
peddle the trump russia rumors to the
government and the media and used the
fact trump was being investigated as
part of the campaign messaging so in
other words if you are talking about
russian interference in the election
it's really democratic interference in
the election by suggesting that a chief
issue in the election is whether trump
was a russian cat's paw which as you'll
recall was trotted out by the clinton
team throughout the election cycle
it turns out that the russian probe very
likely was just a piece of fbi
manipulation by the democratic party and
then the fbi had to cover its own ass
and so refused to actually investigate
all of the people thoroughly who had
given it the information in the first
place until now
it's unbelievable eli lake writes for
bloomberg it's been clear for two years
that steel's dossier is garbage that's
mainly thanks to the work of justice
department inspector general michael
horowitz who released a report in 2019
skewering the fbi
durham's investigation has taken a
different approach his last two
indictments suggest the fbi was not a
villain but a victim conned by
democratic operatives to pursue bogus
investigations into the trump campaign
danchenko is charged with hiding his
relationship to a prominent democrat in
interviews with the fbi about the
dossier of course that is charles dolan
as we were discussing
the real victim of these democratic
party deceptions was not the fbi however
says eli lake but the democrat but the
american public that's why durham's
investigation now in its third year
remains not only relevant but vital it
is an incredible thing
so what we have here if we if we've got
this right what we have here is that the
steele dossier which was used as the
basis for the fbi opening and
investigation
into donald trump's campaign which ended
up splashed across the front pages of
every major newspaper in 2016 and then
after the election ended up being the
basis of the mueller investigation
which dogged trump for four years
and in frustration at which trump
started making bizarre phone calls and
getting himself in all sorts of legal
hot water it turns out that all of that
was because the media and the fbi
decided to work along with the democrats
in order to take trump down
right that's all that that we're seeing
here
and it took years
for any of these prosecutions to take
place the fbi it's amazing the fbi knew
daenchenko was lying in 2017 in 2017.
the calendar now says according to my
calculations that it is 2021 what was
the fbi doing all of this time
institutional trust with the fbi has
been broken for quite a while it should
be broken even further
these institutions
they are motivated by politics politics
have infused them when donald trump
talked about the so-called deep state
people took that to mean that there was
an active conspiracy of people working
inside these departments sometimes that
that may be true right there are a lot
of these people who are working together
obviously if you're looking at for
example peter strzok and and lisa page
if you're looking at that coupling and
those people clearly had a similar
priorities but
in reality all this means that there is
a
feedback loop of people who share the
same political echo chamber and you can
apparently retail any piece of garbage
to the fbi
and so long as it is coming from a
democratic source they won't even check
into the sources of the original dossier
they won't even check into it and then
they will launder it this is what james
comey did they will launder it
through the press to the public
and help to destroy the presidency of a
sitting president of the united states
that is an amazing amazing thing listen
i was loathe to believe a lot of the
early charges there are some people who
are on this way earlier now as that is
for damn sure
that's because i have a certain level of
baseline american trust in these
institutions that trust has been deeply
shaken if it hasn't been shaken for you
it's because you're not watching this
closely enough
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video